Okay, let's go to the phones at six one seven,
eight three zero 47 50.
Uh, why don't we start with our color from
the 707 area code caller from seven one seven.
Uh, tell me who you are and where you're calling
from.
Hello.
I'm David.
Hey David.
Where are you calling from?
I don't notice.
I'm asking [inaudible] sure it can be, you
know, to get my heart rate down, you know,
um, never really called into a show before.
All right, good.
But so your name is David or it's not David.
Hi, my name is Nathan.
Okay.
So your name is Nathan.
Yeah, so I've actually been watching the show
for a little bit.
Great.
I grew up in the area, the great room family,
but I still really don't left wing politics
through your show and Kyle Quincey show and
I mostly agree with you in a lot of things,
but like what?
I'm going to have a hard time like, uh, understanding
your point of view is immigration.
Right?
Okay.
Well, like I do see that they are people.
I see this, I'm like people worry a little
bit.
It'll be a decent dehumanizing into language.
Wait, at least go.
The grants is a little bit like in the car
taking weight.
He's mad at me kind of.
Right.
But um, but like I mean I understand what
you're reading that well, but I also took
need to have law us, right.
Because if people come in across the border,
um, well, well I, I feel like they should,
I'm definitely for it integration before.
I think they should be easier if people are
coming here because they want refugees.
Right?
Yeah.
Nathan, let me just, I mean, let me cut right
to it.
Who is saying that there should be no border
control and no immigration laws?
I haven't heard anybody say that.
Oh No.
Yeah, that's a good, that's a good huh?
Bitlink hyper.
But we've seen that's like the only, like
the only frames, nothing people are for open
borders.
I, if they don't agree with,
yeah.
So Am I.
There's no, there's no reasonable chance that
totally open board.
I mean totally open borders is not being considered
seriously in any way.
So I questioned the value of, I mean, of course
you disagree with that.
I disagree with that, but it seems that we
should really be focusing the discussion on
the sort of more, more real world to disagreements
that there are, in other words, when the president
talks about as whole countries and where people
should be coming from or when we talk about
the um, uh, idea of building a wall and what
it means financially and what it means in
other ways it seems.
Yes, sure.
Some people might want totally open borders,
but there there's zero chance that it's going
to be a reality.
And I don't even know why we would sort of
art even spend time arguing against that
robot here.
We locked that like affiliates our borders
a little bit under secured if people could
like walk across and I'm not for a wall.
Yeah.
Waste of money.
But um, I would be for like maybe like increase
in border security as far as if I can work
at your like Turing, um, tighter.
But I think like the idea that like the borders,
is that a creative decision border is the
way it should be or what is your position?
Well, no sir.
So we, we've, if we want to control more of
what is happening illegally at the border
and more generally with immigration, with
more generally with immigration, we need to
look at what's happening with overstayed visas,
which represent a huge portion of people that
are here illegally.
They're not crossing the border at the border.
Most of the drugs are coming through ports
of entry.
So of course we should use both technology
and people, uh, whether it's border patrol,
customs, whatever.
Uh, and, and mostly Democrats are in favor
of that.
So again, I feel like we want to be really
careful when you say you disagree with me
so far.
It sounds like we agree 100%.
Okay.
They just didn't understand your position.
But um, that could be cool cocaine.
That's clearly not coming home for southern
border.
Yes.
That's also true.
Nathan, listen, I'm going to let you go because
it does sound like you're underwater and I
don't know what's causing that.
But I do appreciate the phone call and I look
forward to welcoming you, uh, back on the
program once again in the future.